like writing a book
I loved it my husband would come in and
see me you know in my pajamas sitting at
the kitchen table absorbed and he'd
leave go to work come back and I'd still
be there smiling and laughing to myself
yeah like he said I've never seen this
what's going on I said I have no idea
but I love it what did you love about it
I loved
not being in my own head and going as if
through a portal into this other world
and and Through The Eyes of this
character I created I could live her
experience the good the bad the sexy the
scary you know and get a break from my
own life
and in the clear Light Of Summer his
opal irises seared into me and I
retraced my path to memorize the solid
radius and temperature of him and
finally let go